dans un instant vous saurez tous sur la
Guille en course 20e édition le 7 avril
mais déjà retour sur le championnat
régional de boxe éducative à la verrière
et la victoire du jeune espoir Lucas
Fèvre qui a remporté son match en 3
roundes Anthony res et cl Cambier pour
les images
justement après la rasère de titre chez
les minimes le Boxing de la verrière
fondait ses espoirs de titre régional
chez les benjamins sur salimed ce JEE
verrieri mais les gants depuis 4 ans et
manilard du contre avec précision Salim
il est il se débrouille pas mal il
manque un peu de de sérieux non pas de
régularité parce qu'il vient souvent il
est pas tout le temps très appliqué un
peu un peu on va dire tête en l'air pour
faire ça en
expression mais voilà sinon sinon il y a
du potentiel bien sûr qu'est-ce que tu
ressens quand tu sur du
ring une envie de
gagner trop timide pendant l'assaut son
chemin s'arrêtera en demi-finale dans
l'autre coin Lucas Fèvre suit les traces
de son frère ancien triple champion de
France il participe à la verrière à son
premier championnat régional sur
puissant dans sa catégorie Lucas et son
propre ennemi dans une discipline où le
contrôle de soi est vital pour un jeune
de son âge 11 ans il fait mal et en boxe
éducatif ce qui est c'est la touche donc
avec lui ce qu'il faut c'est surtout le
le canaliser pour pas blesser et pour
pas être disqualifié parce que les
règlements en boxe éducatif ils sont
très très stricts souvent plus grand que
ses adversaires il a plus d'allonge
c'est d'ailleurs le cas en finale du
tournoi le sort du combat est vite
scellé Lucas Fèvre devient le nouveau
champion régional Benjamin de box
éducative au bout des TR
roundes le problème de Lucas vu qu'il
frappe j'avais peur que son adversaire
lu rendre dedans en fait et ça sa pas
donc ça s très bien passé pour nous en
fait Lucas on lui a fait profiter pour
faire travailler ses déplacement il a
fait un très bel assaut je suis très
content de lui 20e édition de la Guille
en course le 7 avril 10 km 500 particip
attendu je reçois sur ce plateau Sophie
bossonet bonsoir vous êtes bénévole du
club l'Entente Athlétique de
Saint-Quentin depuis une dizaine
d'années max bonsoir à vous vous êtes
président de ce club vous vous chargez
donc de l'organisation de ce rendez-vous
la Guille en course à 20 ans comment est
né ce rendez-vous alors ce rendez-vous
est né en 93 mais en octobre non pas en
avril à la base donc Alain boucher qui
qui n'est plus aujourd'hui sur 5
liveline mais avec qui on a toujours des
contacts étit à l'époque donc le le
créateur de de cette Guy en course qui
venait à l'issue d'une ancienne course
qui s'appelait la trace de la Bièvre qui
avait été arrêtée par une organisation
qui n'était pas sur guuille en cours à
l'époque mais qui était une course tout
à fait reconnue en Île-de-France et donc
Alen a eu l'idée de de prendre le
parcours qui était sur la ville de Guill
encour la partie Guill encour donc
autour des étantes de la minière et de
créer cette première édition en octobre
93 aujourd'hui c'est devenu un
rendez-vous incontournable pour les
coureurs
incontournable 20 ans vingtaine
d'édition c'est c'est assez conséquent
oui oui c'est c'est conséquent disons
que c'est un rendez-vous local avant
tout et puis un rendez-vous très
convivial et de plus en plus familial
quand il y aura quatre courses
effectivement en dehors de ce
rendez-vous fard des 10 km sur lequel on
va s'attarder tout à l'heure il y a deux
courses de 1 km pour les plus petits une
autre de 2,2 km pour les un petit peu
plus grand rendez-vous véritablement
familial vous insistez sur ce point oui
il y aura des courses des courses
enfants donc des enfants de 8 ans
jusqu'à 15 ans donc de mini poussin
jusqu'à Benjamin ce sont des courses
accessibles pour eux il faut déjà avoir
un petit peu ou faut quand même aller
faut quand même avoir couru parce que
quand ils partent ils partent très très
vite et il faut les modérer combien de
temps il mettre pour faire 1 km les plus
petits combien de temps c'est réglé oh
écoutez en 3 minutes les les premiers
souvent sont sont pas loin d'avoir
franchi la ligne d'arrivée si c'est si
c'est oui parce que ça va ça va vite
comme dit Sophie on les on les maîtrise
sur de ou 300 m pour éviter les les
accidents de départ et puis les départs
trop trop rapide mais après on a on a
déjà canaliser un petit peu les énergies
pour les plus jeunes les courses vont
s'échelonner tout au long de la matinée
le rendez-vous phare à 10h 10 km ça
c'est le rendez-vous pour les sportifs
les plus aguéris oui vous pouvez nous
présenter un petit peu ce parcours de 10
km donc le parcours le départ se fait du
gymnase des droits de l'homme à 10h il y
a à peu près 700 m de route sur la route
de saint-sy ensuite on part dans les
chemins de boireovert donc les forêts la
forêt de qui à cheval entre saint-cire
lescole aiguille en cours et ensuite on
descend sur l'étend du moulin renard ou
qu'on appelle les étends de la minière
et on fait un tour de l'étend du moulin
renard et ensuite bah il faudra remonter
donc il y aura une belle côte et pour
tout ça pour revenir toujours par le
bois le Bois Robert et ensuite bah pour
revenir au gymnase des droits de l'homme
qui participe à cette course justement
ce sont plutôt des sportifs des
licenciés du club de Lea Saint-Quentin
d'autres d'autres clubs viennent
quelques licenciés de a Saint-Quentin
seront là mais ils seront aussi beaucoup
bénévoles euh des licenciés des autres
clubs seront là des gens non licenciés
des ce qu'on appelle des des coureurs du
dimanche aussi euh certains font une
course dans l'année et c'est la guuille
en course parce que c'est le parcours
sur lequel il s'entraîne le weekend et
c'est vrai que le parcours est agréable
et en plus s il fait beau c'est ce sera
le somme jusqu'à 550 550 participant
limité on a limité les participants à
550 euh ça ça il y a encore de la place
il y a encore de la place y encore de la
place 303 voilà tout à l'heure on était
à 303 inscrits le jour même ce sera
encore possible de s'inscrire Vous avez
évoqué le samedi aussi on peut s on peut
venir au gymnase des droits de l'homme
pour s'inscrire jusqu'à la dernière
minute avec le départ donc un petit peu
avant quand même la dernière minute
dernier quart d'heure voilà juste le
temps de de rejoindre la ligne de départ
ensuite AG guuill en cours pour cette
20e édition vous parliez des bénévoles
tout à l'heure vous êtes combien
actuellement à travailler sur ce projet
l'organisation alors on est un collectif
on est une dizaine de
personnes euh qui formons un collectif
d'organisation le collectif est mené par
André petigjan qui n'a pas pu venir ce
soir avec nous
représentons parmi les bénévoles donc le
collectif travaille en amont donc ça
fait 6 mois qu'on travaille quand même
sur laaguill en course et le jour Mo
travail c'est pour quoi c'est pour
repérer le parcours pour prévoir tout
tout ce qu'il faut prévoir B pour pour
instaurer pour instaurer les dossiers
faire les demandes àant préfecture
mettre en route
les les relations avec les mairies la
casquille qui nous ont beaucoup aidé
essayer de chercher trouver des des
sponsors donc tout ça c'est du travail
c'est fait par des bénévoles qui ontin
un travaill à côté donc il faut s'y
prendre quand même à l'avance et vous
serez jusqu'à une soantaine le jour de
la alors on a 74 bénévoles du club et et
amis du club qui viendront le samedi et
le dimanche et en plus on sera aussi
bien soutenu par les services municipaux
de la mairie de guillancour h puisque
nous aurons des des personnes du service
des sports de la mairie qui viendront
nous aider c'est très lourd pour un club
d'organiser ce ce genre de rendez-vous
parce que vous en organisez plusieurs le
aqu en plus tout au long de l'année oui
c'est ce que j'allais dire en fait oui
l'événement lui-même c'est toujours quel
que soit la la popularité la densité des
des participants bon c'est toujours un
travail comme l'a dit Sophie ça se
prépare longtemps à l'avance parce qu'on
est que des bénévoles donc c'est des
réunions le soir de temps en temps en
fonction des dispos de de chacun et la
difficulté pour le club oui c'est que
benah des événements comme ça on est
déjà il y a le trail desamou en octobre
là il y a la Guille en course en avril
dans 2 mois il y aura le 10 km d'l
encours donc on a réussi et ça j'avoue
que je suis assez fier de ça parce que
au sein du club il fallait arriver à on
peut pas grandir grandir sans organiser
un petit peu toutes les parties du club
après il faut fédérer tout ça c'est un
petit peu le travail du Président entre
autres donc et c'est vrai que là on a
trois trois courses qui sont
assez anciennes pour certaines qui ont
pris beaucoup d'importance qui sont plus
récentes je pense au TR desam et celle
des lancours qui en est qu'à sa deè
édition mais qui semble assez
prometteuse donc à chaque fois on a des
équipes un peu distinctes alors on
retrouve de temps en temps des gens qui
participent un peu à tous les collectifs
heureusement pour nous mais on a essayé
c'était c'était le but et à guillancour
moi je suis content cette année puisque
je continuerai à être bénévole de Jorgie
mais j'ai j'ai je suis sorti bon pour
des problèmes de disponibilité
essentiellement de l'organisation et je
suis content de voir que pour la 20e
édition on a une nouvelle équipe qui qui
se met en place il va faire beau donc
j'ai j'ai pas de doute sur la réussite
bon je sais qu'ils ont un peu de stress
parce que j'ai j'ai connu ça moi aussi
hein quand quand on débute une
organisation bon là message du président
c'est que tout va bien se passer faut
pas s'inquitter la course sera sera un
succès une fois plus bien sûr nous
serons présents et vous pourrez voir les
images dès le lundi 18h30 en direct lors
du prochain 78 sport avec Anthony rche
c'est la 20e édition on peut miser sur
une 40e édition une vingtaine d'années
supplémentaires ou est-ce qu'il a un
moment vous allez vous dire il faut
peut-être passer à autre chose et
justement privilégier des nouvelles
courses comme celles des longcours alors
euh
non on va essayer de continuer même si
tout ça c'est bien lourd parce que je
pense que ce sont des choses très
différentes Sophie l'a bien expliqué
tout à l'heure laagille en course elle a
une une particularité c'est de d'être
dans un site qui est relativement
exceptionnel les étants de la minière et
je pense que la la la très très grande
majorité des gens qui viennent
participer à la guuill enc le font et
viennent pour le site pour l'ambiance
conviviale voire familiale donc pour
pour l'instant je pense que la ville est
toujours derrière nous pour ce genre
d'événement où on n pas du tout dans une
idée de compétition à tout prix loin de
là même si ça reste une compétition
quand x personnes se mettent sur une
ligne de départ il a toujours qui PRC
mais non mais on est quand même vraiment
dans la spécificité donc tant qu'on aura
des gens qui seront en capacité de de
s'occuper de l'événement pour faire en
sorte qu'il se déroule dans les
meilleures conditions possibles on
essaiera de continuer après la limite
effectivement c'est le bénévolant plus
généralement et là en tout cas pour
l'instant pour cette édition tout est
assuré vous êtes chargé de
l'organisation vous nous l'avez dit
nouvelle équipe pour cette Guill en
course 20e édition rendez-vous 9h45 pour
le premier départ si vous voulez suivre
encourager les compétiteurs et puis un
petit peu plus tôt hein si vous voulez
vous inscrire et faire partie des T
derniers participants merci à vous le 78
de ce 4 avil est presque terminé je vous
propose à présent juste de faire un tour
par la ville de trappe nous allons
terminer ce tour de l'actualité locale
par un point sur un salon initié par
l'association les mamans du cœur les
ethnies de la ville étaient à
l'honneur
premier salon oriental organisé par
l'association les mamans du cœur à la
salle Jean-Baptiste Clément de trappe en
l'honneur des 72 ethnies de la ville on
voudrait faire le lien entre les jeunes
et et les entre guillemets vieux parce
que bon les jeunes de traap c'est vrai
qu'ils sont un petit peu mal considérés
on considère que ce des voyou des gens
pas importants et cetera et c'est tout à
fait le contraire au côté de stand de
pâtisseries orientales des
esthéticiennes proposaient des séances
de maquillage de Man C et de aîné
pendant que des jeunes filles assuraient
le CH en défilant avec des robes de
mariage c'est une tenue qui a été
adaptée pour les personnes voilées
l'Occident on le voit bien avec le
busier avec un petit peu de mousseline
légèrement doré avec des matières très
trable et très légère tu aurais envie de
porter une telle robe à ton mariage oui
ça c'est manfa pour la proch fois pour
mon
mariage côté culturel unt propos des
ouvrages consacrés à la à l'éducation
des enfants à l'amour et aussi à la
religion une thématique très présente
pendant le salon tous les bénéfices
devrait être reversé à l'association les
mamans du cœur qui compte désormais 14
nouveaux
adhérents fin du 78 pour cette semaine
l'édition du weekend vous sera présentée
par Anthony Resche dès demain vendredi
moi je vous retrouve lundi 18h en direct
avec de nouveaux invités autour de cette
table excellente
soirée